if you want to hear a story about gutter
politics and a super clear example of
how people's health is basically a
commodity that you can trade and barter
for profit in the u.s. do I have a story
for you health insurer Aetna has been
trying to acquire Humana a competitor we
also learned this week that Aetna has
announced they're going to be pulling
out of the Obamacare exchanges in 11
states it turns out that those are not
two separate stories but are actually
one story Huffington Post Jonathan Cohn
and Geoff young got a copy of a letter
from the CEO of Aetna Mark Bertolini to
the Justice Department from last month
from July fifth and the letter was
written when the government was still
deciding whether to oppose the merger of
Aetna and Humana on the ground that it
would hurt consumers and reduce
competition which it obviously would and
the Bert bertolini letter was in answer
to a request from the Justice Department
for more information about how this
would relate to or affect the Obamacare
exchanges the letter is a pretty direct
threat I'll put a piece of it up on the
screen for you here and it says our
analysis to date makes clear that if the
deal were challenged or blocked we would
need to take immediate action to
mitigate public exchange and Affordable
Care Act small group losses specifically
if the DOJ sues to enjoin the
transaction meaning to stop the merger
we will immediately take action to
reduce our 2017 exchange footprint we
currently plan as part of our strategy
following the acquisition to expand from
15 states to 20 states however if we're
in the midst of litigation over the
Humana transaction given the risks we
described above we will not be able to
expand the five additional states in
addition we would also withdraw from at
least five additional states uh blah
blah blah blah blah uh a little more
than two weeks later July 21st Justice
Department says we are going to sue to
block the Aetna humana deal and the
other proposed merger between anthem and
Cigna and now this week Aetna says we
are going to scale back participation in
those insurance exchanges we are going
to leave 11 states and over 500
these they are taking their ball and
going home Louis yeah uh I mean the what
I like to ask people should your health
before profit right i mean if you answer
yes to that question you are a twisted
soul and this is uh the reason we ended
up with Obamacare instead of something
great yeah is because we can't beat
these companies right Obamacare as a
reminder for all the good things it does
it is a huge profit center it is a boon
for insurers Humana and Cigna and Aetna
they've all had their stock prices go
way up profits are up because the
Affordable Care Act mandates that they
get millions of new customers in this
for-profit world so yet may be true that
on paper they figured out a way to say
that you know the Affordable Care Act
participation in the exchanges is
actually not really a win for us or blah
blah blah but big picture they're
growing their risk pool they are
diversifying their risk and this is a
very good thing and this is attempted
extortion you were talking here about an
attempt to say if you don't let us join
together in spite of the fact that
clearly it would be bad for consumers we
are then going to pull out of the
Obamacare exchanges in the entire system
is a sham and of course most people here
in our audience and you have aetna
insurance more than likely it's through
your employer so you can't really do
anything about it i would suggest try to
get together with your co-workers in
lobby your employer to use somebody else
to try to punish Aetna who they're all
terrible they're they're all the same
yeah they're they're more or less all
the same up very very disturbing and
it's it's legalized extortion they have
a system here Jason where there is
nothing against the law of what about
what they're doing here but it's very
clear that they're saying you don't play
ball with us we're not gonna play ball
with you yeah that's exactly over there
doing in areas where people aren't
actually buying into plans there you
know taking the fines what's what's
happening the insurance companies is
pulling out of the area because they're
not making money therefore the end are
there other is where you know there are
high-risk people doing the same thing
when they actually do do payouts they
just bail out on people no doubt about
it and and that's also part of the year
this a whole other story as far as
opting to take the fine instead
having the insurance and sort of where
that fine money goes and then how it
impacts the insurance company's
decisions to stay or exit the market is
Jason is mentioning disgusting depraved
disaster I don't know how else to say it